Let's talk about the multi party charter
and what it means for these upcoming elections.
In my previous video on voting for small parties
I mentioned how coalitions are going to have a huge
influence in the upcoming elections.
And this multi party charter is a perfect
example of that.
This multi party charter is a pre election agreement
between various political parties
that essentially states they will come together
in a coalition in order to try and prevent the a
N C and E F
F from taking power.
Current members of the multi party charter are the d a
I F P F f plus a C
d p action s a U
C d p U I m
E P p s N P
and I Sanko.
So these parties have essentially agreed
that should none of them get the majority
vote in the national elections
that they will come together
collectively
pull their votes
hoping that that would take them over the 50 + 1
majority needed.
And then they would work together and vote together
in order to elect a president of South Africa.
Their agreement has certain stipulations about how uh
certain positions
will be determined
saying that representation should be approximately
proportional to the votes received in the election
and that merit based
consideration must be made for positions.
And they also specify that it is not necessarily
the case that their presidential candidate
will come from their largest party.
Currently the multi party charter holds
Collectively
112 of the 400 seats available in the National Assembly
by far the largest share coming from the d.
A with 84 seats
and 20% of the vote at the 2019 elections.
So some significant growth from
any number of these parties
would be needed for them to actually
be able to form a majority coalition.
However, one of the members is Action s.
A and Action s.
A is currently an extra parliamentary party
meaning that they have no seats in parliament because
they were not around at the time of the 2019 elections.
There is a chance that this multi party charter
with action s.
A and potentially
if they gain new members
as we get closer to the election
could come close to reaching that 50% plus one majority,
especially if Action s.
A is taking votes from parties like the a N.
C and not winning over voters from the d. A itself.
So that is the multi party charter.
It is important to note that all of these parties
remain as individual parties
and will be listed
individually on the election ballots.
So we will be discussing each
individual party in this multi party charter
in more depth in the future.
But for now
that's kind of a brief
overview of what exactly the multi party charter is
and how it might affect the upcoming
national elections.